Thirty Something Nerdy Critics(3x)
Raging over nothing...
GEEKY POWER!
They're the world's most sheltered whitey teens
Critic: We're really white
These heroes in a nutshell and they're geeks
Hey, go fuck your mother
When the evil bay attacks
These boys will show, he's a motherfucking hack
Thirty something nerdy critics(2x)
T.V. Taught them 'bout the turtle teens
We wasted our lives to this thing
Nerd reviews bad games, Critic reviews bad movies
SPACE JAM STILL FUCKING SUCKS
And that's really all that there is
What you're hearing now are filling lyrics!
CATCHPHRASE!!!!
Thirty something nerdy critics(3x)
Raging over nothing...
GEEKY POWER!